- [Salman] Welcome to the Khan
Academy 2016 Annual Report.
In the actual text of the report,
we're going to go into a lot more detail
on the financials and other things,
but I'm hoping here to
give you an overview.
Big picture,
2016 was a great year for Khan Academy.
The impact has continued to grow
in the double-digit percentages
and is accelerating.
So one of the areas that
we've really started
to accelerate in 2016 was
in content development.
Many people associate Khan
Academy with mathematics,
but what we've really been investing in
is going beyond mathematics.
We really want to cover all
of the core academic subjects
that you consider to be
part of your education,
all the way through the core of college.
And it's not just videos,
we're doing a lot on practice,
and we're doing a lot of written articles.
2016 was a very big deal
in terms of a partnership
with the College Board.
A few years ago, they reached out to us,
said, "We are going to revamp the SAT,
"and as part of that we
want to address at least
"the perception of inequity
that's been around for decades."
And the reason why they wanted
to partner with Khan Academy
is traditional test prep was
associated with gaming an exam.
It wasn't about real learning.
But they saw that we were
focused on filling in gaps
in students understanding,
so we launched with the College Board.
And what we've seen over
the course of the year is
Khan Academy is now used more than
all of paid test prep combined,
and we're seeing that usage
very broad and very deep.
And what's been even more
exciting is the PSAT,
which is taken in 10th or 11th grade
by 80% of American high school students.
In the past, that was just a
random practice test you took,
but now it acts as a
diagnostic for Khan Academy.
You can take your PSAT scores,
give permission to Khan Academy,
and then Khan Academy software
knows your strengths and weaknesses,
not just in math but in
reading and writing as well,
and can immediately
give you practice items
that are essentially weak point training.
And even more powerful, we've
been able to follow students
from that PSAT through
their work on Khan Academy
to eventually taking the SAT,
to understand the efficacy
of this entire ecosystem.
And what you see here on this slide
are some of the preliminary
results for arguably
the largest personalized
learning study ever conducted.
With over 300,000 students,
we saw that those who
prepared on Khan Academy
for at least 20 hours saw twice the growth
from the PSAT to the SAT than
they would typically see,
and this is just the beginning.
We're working with the
College Board very closely
to do even further studies,
and we've also seen that it
doesn't stop at 20 hours.
The more time that
students put in practice,
the more gains were seen.
Another really exciting event in 2016
is that Duck Duck Moose
became part of Khan Academy.
Duck Duck Moose, I would argue,
was the best early learning
app company out there.
In 2016, the founding team
said, "We would rather see our
work having a social mission
"and reaching as many
students as possible,
"especially those that are most in need."
And so they became part
of our team in 2016.
And going forward,
we're going to be working
on early learning apps
that holistically approach
reading, writing, mathematics,
starting at pre-kindergarten
and then taking students
through early elementary school.
International continues to be
a very big part of Khan Academy.
Roughly 1/3 of our usage is
outside of the United States.
We have increased our focus
on India, Mexico, and Brazil.
And going forward, we're
building tools and platforms
to allow each geography
to be even more localized
to their specific needs.
And going forward, there's
a lot of exciting things.
What you see here is a screenshot
for the student-facing experience
for back to school 2017,
where students can tell Khan Academy
what classes they're taking,
what grade they're in,
and then Khan Academy
can personalize to them.
And also, I have game mechanics
so that the students are
motivated to move forward.
You can see that right over here,
once you get into a unit page.
Of course, you see the videos.
You see the practice items here.
But we are also adding diagnostic quizzes
and unit tests as well.
What you see here is our
assignments functionality,
where a teacher can assign any piece
of content on Khan Academy.
This is a teacher assigning
some practice content.
They can assign it to particular students
in a particular class.
They can set a due date.
They can then see a readout
of which students completed
which assignments.
And then they can see
which items gave the
students the most difficulty
so that they can review
it in class the next day.
On top of all of this,
we have a program called LearnStorm,
which is a learning challenge
that schools, teachers,
students participate in
that celebrate the growth mindset.
The more students can
show grit, perseverance,
as they work through
practice on Khan Academy,
the more awards and recognition
the students, their
classrooms, their teachers,
and their schools will get.
We've piloted it in several
geographies in the past,
and 2017 is going to be the first time
that we do this on a nationwide scale.
So there's a lot going on at Khan Academy.
What I just covered is
really just a sample of it.
But we're really grateful
for your support.
We have a big mission,
a free, world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And some of y'all have been
with us for many years.
When we were just starting in
2007, out of a walk-in closet,
this type of a mission would've
seemed, frankly, delusional.
But because of your
support, your partnership,
all of the work that we've
been able to do together
with governments, with
teachers, with students,
it's no longer just a dream.
It's really happening.
And the momentum that we've
built together in 2016
is continuing to accelerate into 2017,
and I expect is going to
accelerate in 2018 and beyond
so that, as we look
back in a decade or two,
we'll say how could we
ever imagine a world
where there wasn't a free,
world-class education
for anyone, anywhere?